here we are inside the cabin and today
on things I think I know how to do I'm
gonna teach y'all how to make a ladder
or at least how I do it what you need
are some two by sixes your drills don't
forget to get an extra battery cause
it's gonna die I'm using Tim locks these
are really cool for in chores right here
these are like modern-day lag screws
they go in like that they get things
real tight I'm gonna use a lot of them
so I got a big box of 40 other than that
we're gonna use our square our framing
square the big guy you're gonna
definitely need a pencil and to back up
you're also gonna want to have a utility
blade did I mention you definitely need
your speed square so that put that on
the material thing speed square you need
that speed square a big part of this
process is measuring and marking
measuring and marking there's a lot of
repetition when you're making a ladder
and it's all about measuring and marking
and the first thing we're gonna measure
is the angle that this ladder is at that
we want it to be at the way we're gonna
do that is not actually by taking a
measurement and angular measurement this
is how I do it people might not like it
it's very intuitive way to do it all
right but maybe not the most
professional I don't know but this is
how I do it I take the board that I'm
gonna use and I put it right where I
want it to land on the floor then I lean
it up right where I want it to lean on
the loft up top I take my ladder move it
over here and I open it up so I could I
could go like this right and I could go
down here to where I think the angle is
and there's probably a way to get it all
lined up on this thing and I don't never
really know how to do that there's a way
to do it with a what's called a bevel
gauge which is like a little thing like
this and you can see what the angle is I
don't have one of those so here's what I
do I take my square and I put it down
there so it's flat on the floor this is
going to be the angle this is the angle
that
need it's right there now what I'm gonna
do this is like a hack I'm not a hack
this is like a hack doesn't that mean
something when you hack something yeah
like you hack something's like a way to
do something now that I have my line
that I know is that the exact same plane
that this floor floats out on that tells
me what the angle that I'm gonna cut it
at is so it will sit flat on the floor
because guess what this plane the floor
right here is the same as that plane so
that means whatever angle this is that's
the same angle this is what I love about
math how I have this line marked so what
I'm gonna do is I put my speed square on
it I put my little corner right down
there and thing ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding BAM and make sure my
speed score is perfectly covering the
line 15 right there so I know that if I
cut this at 15 and that at 15 then it
will sit perfectly at the angle that I
want it to sit back it's cool it's math
you use it last thing I've got to do up
here is figure out the tread width I
know that OSHA the safety folks say that
it needs to be at least 16 inches clear
width that means not the width of the
whole ladder but the width of this the
tread and those treads can't be more
than 12 inches apart so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna measure this space right
in here in order to fit my treads are
gonna be 17 inches wide 17 inches wide
will let the ladder fit in here also fit
fit in to safety regulations and we're
good to go so now I'm gonna go down and
cut a couple of these and a whole bunch
of 17 inch treads and we're gonna
assemble our ladder downstairs now we're
over here we're cutting the treads
there's 17 inches long I could sit down
and measure 17 inches make a little tick
mark make a cut and then do that over
and over and over again I think we need
like 12 treads I'm gonna just do it once
here's what I do I mark it at 17 BAM I'm
gonna make this a nice cut and I'm gonna
know that this cut is 17
[Music]
so I'm going to take my template my
17-inch template piece I'm gonna put it
on top of the next one so we've got nice
and smooth nice and smooth nice and
smooth I'd lower the blade a little bit
all right without putting my finger on
the trigger
I bring the board in and I push it tight
this is exactly where this saw was when
it cut this top piece this is flush here
flush here if this is in the exact same
place that means it's when it cuts the
board below it it's going to be exactly
the same width and on this we want our
treads to be as close to being exactly
the same width as possible now I have
two pieces that are nearly identical and
I'm gonna just do that like 10 times 11
one to grow on
and then I'm gonna cut the other parts
the runners I think are the the rungs I
don't know the ones that go up so I got
my boards cut I got two identical pieces
right here eleven identical 17-inch
treads right here now I just got to
assemble it like I said a huge part of
this is measuring and marking and
getting it ready and what you're always
trying to do is find a little shortcuts
like the way I was cutting these treads
right here that's the shortcut here's
another one got my tape measure I'm
making sure that this is flush right
here hole with my tape measure all right
and I'm gonna pull it out along this
whole thing like this now I'm gonna come
back and I'm gonna make a little mark
every 10 and 3/4 bingo I'm off by like a
quarter-inch at the very top and you
know what that's close enough for
government work and that's and that's
not a partisan comment that just I just
you know what now what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna carry this line to both of
these so I can mark the angles on both
of them so here's what I do I'm gonna
fold this open like this I'm gonna go
over to here where my first mark is and
I mark 15 degrees and then I slide to my
next mark and I'm all right 15 degrees
and I'm making sure that my marks are
going with the bottom in the same
direction the same angle as the bottom
of my ladder I'm gonna go
I'm gonna mark all of this up this
angles on both of these alright so these
are all marked up where they need to go
and what positions delay my treads into
place like this now that they're all
laid out like that I'm gonna take this
and I flip it up I can see my lines
where just like this one
where the top of this is gonna be I'm
getting it trying to get it as close as
I can but I'm not super I'm not trying
to get it super perfect right now
because this is just to hold it into
place while I screw it together now I'm
just gonna go one at a time I'm gonna
screw this one in and when that one's
tight I'm gonna screw this end in right
here now I know I have my two ends in
it's very unlikely to fall then I'm
gonna come back I'm gonna get this one
all lined up this one lined up I'm gonna
go peek under here make sure that it's
right on the line where it should be
then I get to flip it drill it on the
other side pop it into place and we get
to run up to the law two steps to the
drilling process a pre drill with this
right here
I set the Tim lock that's a brand name I
don't know what they're really called
I said it with this I pre-drill with
this I'm gonna get this lined up the way
it should be I'm gonna put the nose of
the tread flush you know what that means
right here you could measure this out
you could countersink it and put little
golden diamond plated plugs in if you
want to get anything you want like I
said this is a little bit more wood
butchery so let's do it
a little wood butcher
[Music]
BAM that's tight now yes it's true I'm
just guessing kind of where this lines
up I stand again I stand up above it I
look over I see does it line up with it
and I'm I'm hoping that through
experience I can kind of judge where it
is now these are all screwed in and
they're flush right here so I'm ready to
flip it do the same thing to the other
side it should be a little faster
because now they're securely held in the
right angle in the right position
[Music]
all right let's pop it into place here
we go
oh that's plush looks like it fits flush
down here see what it looks like from up
top oh yes the transition from
downstairs to the loft is now nearly
flawless with our new ladder thank you
for tuning in two things I think I know
how to do I'm sure I'll have something
more for you later so check it out bye
[Music]
[Applause]
please be sure to LIKE and subscribe
this channel so you never miss an update
and please back us on patreon so we can
keep these free videos coming yes free
eight free we need you back us please